know it's crazy because I um joke a lot
about being single and I'm 46 years old
and while I'm getting ready for surgery
and everything it dawned on me that I'm
46 years old and I don't have a husband
to take care of me I don't have a
husband to get ready being single and
46 sucks it just
sucks and I'm [__] tired and I make
jokes about the [__] buffoons that I
have been encountering in and dating
this is my reality and this those
stories are the [__] that's available
because all the good men have gotten
married 20s and 30s cuz they're good men
typically when you hear women's
reasoning for wanting a husband and it's
a selfish thing it's about them
typically that's the reason why they
haven't been able to get one